the New York Post cover today Title Wave
alarm
cities in every contiguous state getting
ready for the federal government to
allow thousands of mostly unvetted
people to Fan out across America
a new op-ed keying in on the chaos in El
Paso here's a look at that video again
we showed you that overrun facility the
headline says the city's migrant state
of emergency is a taste of what nation
faces as Biden shrugs at border crisis
he shrugs at this
Sheriff Mark Daniels of Cochise County
Arizona Lieutenant Chris Oliveira's from
the Texas Department of Public Safety uh
let's start in Cochise County right now
where the drugs are flowing in such a
manner Sheriff Daniels that gets less
talk about you know in terms of our
coverage right now because we don't have
as many people coming across but
fentanyl oh my goodness like never
before
Harris good morning let me let me just
say that hours ago I was on a scene
where there was death there was fentanyl
there was smuggling there was assault on
my deputies that was just several hours
ago smuggling from the border into our
communities and talking to my Deputy
that was trying to save a guy's life
when another car came by and hit that
individual that Smuggler and killed him
so again this goes on every day in
Cochise County we're dealing with
smuggling we deal with uh the human
smuggling part of it the drugs you name
it we're seeing it and what we don't see
is prioritization from President Biden
Congress all I hear is the blame game
was that person this person we're not
doing that we're not doing that and the
acknowledgment we have a problem in this
border Harris we have a problem on our
Southwest border
well look we do
1933 miles of it and we're looking right
now at Texas uh the the background video
that you see there pulling into focus is
from our exclusive look that we got when
I was with Lieutenant Oliveira's in that
Del Rio Texas uh just a short few weeks
ago right as the fiscal year was ending
Lieutenant oliveros first of all how
much worse has it gotten since you and I
did the night time ride-along that we
did and saw so many people dressed in
camo trying to sneak their way in
well good morning Harrison thanks for
having me on great to be with you so of
course you saw it firsthand when you're
out there with us so not just the work
that our Troopers are doing on private
ranches trying to apprehend illegal
immigrants that are trying to circumvent
checkpoints but also the human smuggling
you got to win this first hand too much
smug was actually smuggling illegal
immigrants further into the into our
country and since then to Harris there's
been a significant increase in human
smiling especially in the Del Rio sector
and also I just want to touch on what
the sheriff mentioned about as far as
drugs one thing Harris that's very
concerning to us as a state is the fact
that when title 42 is lifted we're going
to see a mass uh flow of migration that
we've never seen before in years
historic years I mean this what we're
seeing right now is historic right but
it's kind of hard to put into Wars how
much divorce can they get but even
Congressman Gonzalez had mentioned it's
going to be a hurricane of mass you know
legal migration taking place but when
that takes place the cartels Mexican
cartels use that to their advantage you
know that the distraction is going to be
the fact that all the focus is going to
be on this Mass groups that are coming
across our borders and it's going to
leave miles and miles of borders on
patrol where there's no enforcement
actually being taken so that's a concern
right now as far as the drugs or
anything it's going to take place thank
you let me just step in right there
because I want to bring back uh the
sheriff Daniels for just a moment
because you you two could almost talk to
each other about this because you
brought up the very next point for me
lieutenant oliveiras and that is what
happens when everybody's concentrated on
where the people are trying to cross
illegally and just coming in a wave
to Nogales for for instance where the
drugs have reached a point now of Epic
Proportions let's pop that up on the
screen while I ask Sheriff Daniels about
how do you deal with this I mean look at
those numbers that the fiscal year just
ended
and I mean nearly one million pounds 22
pounds of fentanyl powder from Smugglers
were just taken Customs and Border
Protection has seized more than 14 000
pounds of fentanyl in all of fiscal year
2022. that's up by ten thousand
I mean how can you handle that sheriff
well it's how can America handle that
heresy impact that we continue we
continue to see a slippery slope in our
country as a result of the Southwest
border not being prioritized by this
Administration and President Biden what
I keep hearing is we're gonna we don't
have a problem number one for the
administration we know that's false
narrative number two is this is as long
as we keep ignoring it it's only going
to get worse in America we have to
prioritize our border remember the oath
of office I take our Governor's take
mayor's taking our president take we
need to protect this country right now
we're not doing it we have to work
together Harris and until we do that
until we recognize there's a problem in
Washington D.C where Washington says hey
we got to do something better
acknowledge it we can do it better we
can fix this problem but right now I
don't see any hope right now I this is
my first opportunity to talk with you
since what we saw last week American
police officers now trying to handle
crime situations fentanyl is so
pervasive it's everywhere and we saw an
officer have to be treated three times
with a drug to prevent her death from
coming into contact with somebody who
had fentanyl substance on them what are
the dangers now to protect the residents
of America
Sheriff
oh I'm sorry I thought you're talking
sorry well first of all we got to
acknowledge it we have to acknowledge it
Harris that there is a problem when
you're losing 300 Americans a day for a
drug overdose or poisoning and we're not
even acknowledging that and and just
amazes me I've never my 38 years I've
been doing this I just can't imagine our
elected leaders nationally are not
saying let's come together let's engage
with sheriffs Mayors Governors Troopers
let's fix this problem because we can
fix it if we work together but until we
do that
I I'm I'm very worried
well I pray for our law enforcement and
our border patrol and what they're doing
in Texas and Arizona every day the
action that's being taken though isn't
enough for our border patrol and I want
to go back to Lieutenant Oliveira's
you introduced me to so many of our
great men and women with Texas DPS and
border patrol down in your state and
when I read about the suicides now that
are happening because there's so much
they're just overwhelmed with border
patrol what does that look like on the
ground Lieutenant
well you know Harris we try to provide
as much support as we can to border
patrol I mean I'm out there I try to be
out there once again every single day
working with them alongside them
um just and also try to capture the work
that they're doing because a lot of it
obviously not allowing media access not
showing the work that's being done by
border patrol so we try to go out there
and capture that and show the great work
they're doing day in and day out trying
to protect the front lines but they
don't get enough support they don't get
enough credit for what they do yeah and
of course I mean they're doing amazing
work right now in conjunction with what
we're doing as far as a state but they
need all the support they can get right
now we talk about the drugs we're
talking about the prevalence that are
coming across and how are the situation
is going to get much worse and how the
sheriff mentioned that we all need to
get we all need to come together and
protect this and protect this country
and of course border patrol needs to
support you need to get the credit from
the federal government that they need
and they're not getting that they're not
being acknowledged well they are going
to send money
well yeah they're going to send money
but that's all it's going to do here is
all it's going to do is process these
individuals more and get them out into
the country faster it's not going to
stop the problem it's not going to solve
the situation so and one thing I want to
touch on just recently uh a Texas judge
moved in favor of the State of Texas to
re so the federal government can have to
actually re-implement their Mexico
policy so that is perfect timing but
again you know are they going to do it
that's a question that remains to be
seen because they have not acknowledged
the fact that we have a price on this
situation right now I want to thank you
both it is so important that you bring
us the stories from where they're
happening and Sheriff Daniels who speak
with so much wisdom if we can't come
together on protecting our nation's
sovereignty
we've got real big problems in this
country but we can solve them it is
still the greatest country on the planet
good to see you both thank you very much
God bless you for the work that you do
thank you Harrison Merry Christmas thank
you guys hey everyone I'm Emily compagno
catch me and my co-host Harris Faulkner
and Kaylee mcinenney on outnumbered
every weekday at 12 pm Eastern or sets
your DVR also don't forget to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights